سمح لابو دلو القاء نظره اخيره قبل هدم
منزله وهو اوفر حظا من الاف العوائل التي
دمرت منازلها بشكل كامل بفعل الزلزال
الاخير الذي ضرب سوريا وتركيا
اخلاء بس بس كان عندي البراد انكسر كمان
كان عندي تلفزيونات تنكسروا
تغيرت ملامح المدن والبلدات وسويت احياء
بالارض امتلات الجدران الصامده بعبارات
تقيم حاله كل منزل بعد بدء الدفاع المدني
مرحله جديده لرفع الانقاذ وهدم جميع
المنازل الايه التي للسقوط
بلغت الخسائر الاجماليه شمال غرب سوريا
فقط اكثر من خمسه مليارات دولار بحسب
السلطات المحليه تشمل المرحله الثانيه
ايضا ازاله الانقاض التي ضربها هذا
الزلزال وايضا ازاله انقاب المنازل التي
قيمت عبر مهندسين مختصين والتي كانت تشكل
خطرا على حياه اهلنا المدنيين لكنها حكومه
النظام السوري او المنظمات الدوليه
والمحليه لم تصدر اي تعهدات تتعلق بتعويض
العوائل التي باتت تفتقر لكل مقومات
الحياه البسيطه اللازمه لمرحله التعافي من
الكارثه بلشنا من 86
حجره وراء حجره عشر سنين لخلصنا بناء
البيت كامل خمس سنين لخلصنا نص غرفتين
وصالون بعد بعد اربع سنين لحتى اجمعنا نحن
كنا موظفين يا ابني البيت ما بحسن صلته
انا وضعه شايفينه حرج مزبوط ولا لا وضعه
يعني شايفينهم يحاول من قدرت لهم النجاه
جمع بقايا اشيائهم خلال هدم منازلهم علها
تساندهم في رحله نزوحهم الجديده ليضاف 240
الف شخص الى عداد النازحين في الشمال
السوري بلا حلول مؤقته او مستدامه ترك
اصحاب هذه المنازل احياءهم الى غير رجعه
بعد اخلائها وستح المساعدات الدوليه ولا
وجود اي تعويضات دوليه او محليه بعد كارثه
الزلزال
مسلم سيد عيسى العربيه بلده ارمناز ريفو
ادلب الشمالي